on n'a pas réussi à prouver qu'on
pouvait guérir ducobu de 19 avec de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine mais on peut
utiliser cette molécule pour réduire le
nombre d'accidents de trottinettes
ok c'est une blague mais la revue asian
journal of medicine un elfe la prise
très au sérieux elle a d'ailleurs publié
un article dans ce sens un article
complètement bidon son titre vise
d'ailleurs le médecin qui a popularisé
l'hydroxyde chloroquine contrairement
aux attentes le sar skov deux plus létal
que les trottinettes
est-ce que l'hydroxyde chloroquine
pourrait être la seule solution c'est
une référence à peine voilée à une
citation du professeur didier raoult ndt
le fervent défenseur de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine avait en février dernier
intitulé l'une de ses chroniques médical
coronavirus moins de morts que par
accident de trottinettes
mais passons peut-être que la référence
a pu échapper aux correcteurs de la
revue asiatiques
écoutez plutôt le nom des auteurs de
l'article didier l'embrouillé
silvano trottine et à hauteur fantôme
mêmes nemo macron en référence aux
chiens du couple présidentiel
l'article est criblé de référence
humoristique elle présente en plus une
méthodologie plus que douteuse
les études 1 et 2 ont été conduites
depuis la chaise des auteurs en france
le 20 juillet 2020 l'étude 3 a été
réalisée dans le parking d'une usine
abandonnée
l'objectif des auteurs est clair dénoncé
le manque de sérieux de certaines revues
scientifiques
nous on s'est dit en voyant le site
c'est pas sérieux du tout donc on va
faire d'une pierre deux coups on va
publiée dans ce journal en essayant de
faire l'étude la plus idiote possible en
faisant le plus de blagues possible pour
pouvoir passer un message que si ça peut
passer leurs vieux ving si ça peut être
publié même si s'est retirée très vite
c'est la preuve qu'on peut faire passer
n'importe quoi dans ce genre de revue
pourquoi ont-ils viser cette revue jeu
en particulier parce qu'elle a publié
fin juillet une étude sur l'efficacité
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine combiné
ladite romy sin sur les patients
atteints de formes peu graves de co lead
parmi ces auteurs martin von heure ci
qui a trait député exelero m et violaine
guérin gynécologues endocrinologues et
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
ce canular ne les fait pas rire du tout
réagir aux lignes pondu par trois
rigolos sens moral ne m'intéresse pas on
parle de quoi au juste si ce n'est de
vies perdues nous sommes cliniciens et
les vies sauvées nous importe plus que
l'effet news et les attaques
personnelles qu'il est l'objectif
politique derrière cela que de
s'acharner de cette façon en ce qui
concerne notre article je ne saurais
trop conseiller aux personnes qui se
veut objective de le lire de la première
à la dernière ligne afin de se faire
leur propre opinion puisque nous avons
pris le soin d'argumenter tous les
points de discussion
c'est le fruit du travail de médecins de
terrain qui ont soigné des vrais
patients le pire dans cette histoire
c'est que cet article fictifs et
parodique a bien été relus et validés
par deux éditeurs de l'asian journal of
medicine and wales
une question se pose alors quel est
l'intérêt pour cette revue d'être si peu
regardante peut-être encaisser les frais
de publication
en l'occurrence 85 $ dans le cas qui
nous intéresse
des frais qui peuvent monter jusqu'à 500
dollars c'est ce qu'on appelle une revue
prédatrice sur internet les revues
scientifiques prédatrice ou douteuses ou
parasites ou illégitimes ou peu
scrupuleuses profite pour la plupart du
modèle auteurs payeur de la publication
en libre accès leur but et mercantiles
sans chercher à promouvoir ni pérenniser
les résultats de la recherche
ce n'est pas le premier canular de
l'histoire du monde scientifique
mais quand ils ont pour sujet une
pandémie mondiale
les blagues de ce genre bien qu'elle
devienne virale font rire jaune